hi i'm betsy i'm a tasty producer and
today i'm going to show you how i made
my chocolate cookie cheesecake stuffed
brownies that was a
mouthful
a mouthful i really wanted to combine
three very popular flavors chocolate
cheesecake cookies
so i thought why not throw all three of
those things into a single recipe
together and surprisingly or not
surprisingly it worked really really
well really really well so these
brownies are definitely on the sweeter
side there's a lot of sugar in there and
it's perfectly fine if you want to kind
of cut back on the sweetness and scale
those sugar amounts back
you want to make sure that you're
sifting your dry ingredients together i
know sometimes some people think ugh
it's an extra step but i'm telling you
it's going to be worth it sifting really
adds the benefit of ensuring that your
ingredients are really well mixed and
you're going to get a really nice smooth
batter at the end
so what's awesome about this recipe is
that it makes a very big batch of
brownies so it's perfect for parties or
if you're going to go spend some time
with family and friends
i mean they're super rich super ooey
gooey i probably almost fainted after i
had a bite of one that's how bite shots
work people it's gonna take some arm
strength but you're going to
distribute all of the brownie batter
into the baking sheet and spread it out
evenly you'll pop it in the oven for 25
minutes so there's a lot of debate
around no bake cheesecakes versus baked
cheesecakes
we tried a variety of different
cheesecake recipes for this specific
recipe and at the end we really figured
out that a baked cheesecake filling made
the most sense and worked the best
after 25 minutes you'll take the
brownies out of the oven and use a
quarter cup measuring cup to create
indentations in the brownies you'll
essentially be creating 24 little holes
this is going to give you some space to
distribute your cheesecake filling and
your chocolate sandwich cookies layer
them up baby
what really attracted me to this recipe
was the end result when you see that
bite shot and you see that awesome cross
section like all those layers of the
brownie the cheesecake the cookie like
i was pretty much drooling and i think
everyone else in the kitchen was too
[Music]
do
[Music]
you